would you re-employ someone who is
guilty of a security breach I'm
secretary suena Braverman is the Home
Secretary in charge of the UK security
and just six days after his trust sacked
her for sharing secret documents Rishi
sunak controversially reappointed her
I'm absolutely delighted to the very
same job so who is she what did she do
wrong and why are opposition parties
quite so angry he's done a grubby deal
trading National Security because he was
scared to lose another leadership
election
foreign
[Music]
lawyer was named after Sue Ellen Ewing a
character from the U.S TV series Dallas
we love you over here thank you very
much and bravman certainly seems to be a
magnet for drama she has formed for
resigning quitting as one of Theresa
May's brexit ministers back in 2018 in
protest over the then PM's handling of
the UK's departure from the EU can you
confirm whether or not you have resigned
or are you still in post
some recent memorable moments include
this attack on climate protesters it's
the Coalition of chaos it's the guardian
reading terrible
terrible eating Ro karate dare I say the
anti-growth Coalition and saying of the
government's policy of deporting Asylum
Seekers to Africa I would love to have a
front page of the telegraph with a plane
taking off to Rwanda that's my dream
it's an obsession
so why did Zoella bravman resign this is
the home office running it is one of the
most complex and sensitive roles in
government but Suella bravman hasn't
been great at handling secret
information known by her critics as
leaky Sue she sent confidential
documents using her private email to an
MP outside government and accidentally
forwarded them to a parliamentary
researcher
the Home Secretary made an error of
judgment but she recognized that she
raised the matter and she accepted her
mistake sowella bravaman is a
significant figure on the right of her
party she was chair of the European
research group of Euro skeptic MPS and
then ran for Tory leader when Boris
Johnson resigned she came sixth
Brotherman 27.
therefore under the rules Sue Ella
bravaman
is eliminated from the contest but after
Liz truss quit she backed Rishi sunak to
succeed her an important endorsement and
he rewarded Suleman with her old job
the question to the Home Secretary
about her resignation and reappointment
gone away labor wants an urgent
investigation and claim the pm has
ignored warnings about the risks of the
reappointment and former Home Secretary
David blunkett has warned spies could be
reluctant to share secrets with the UK
If swella bravaman stays in post Suella
bravaman seems safe for now but the
cabinet minister with oversight of MI5
is now been given lessons by that very
security service in how to handle
sensitive information